do any other animals
tend to find their identity in their
color even though they are the same
species like humans with rice
and mammals nothing came to me exactly
although there may well be
um different uh coat colors within um
within non-domesticated species but the
example that really sprang to mind
was you know i know exactly you know
exactly where i'm going
um the bastamentos right
so the boca del toro archipelago in
panama
has uh many delights uh
one of them is uh that it has on it a
species of dark poison frog which was
the first clade of uh
frogs that i was studying with regard to
their sexual selection and territorial
behavior and parental care behavior
um and it's it's no longer gender babies
it's oophagia i think pamelio
and they have in the bocus archipelago
so many morphs it's really incredible so
in costa rica where they are more common
they're called the blue jeans frog
they're bright red on their backs they
have
bright blue legs and if you flip them
over they have these like pale neon blue
dots on their venters and their stomachs
and in mainland panama they tend to not
have blue jeans as much
but on these islands they have every
color under the sun there are yellow
ones they're orange ones there are green
ones they're
[Music]
i don't think purple but sort of deep
blue and of course they're red
and each of them come with spots
sometimes without spots other times
pretty much all the actually
absolutely colored gender batteds the
dark poison frogs have these pale blue
neon blue dots on their stomachs but
when under normal circumstances you
don't normally see frogs flipped upside
down
they look so different from one another
and they do
seem to be mating assortatively based on
color
and so that's a that's a long-winded way
of getting to an answer it's not a
mammal but it is an animal
of an organism that is made doing mate
choice decisions based on
um based on color and
you have something there you want to
well i'm trying to find
uh one of these posters but i want to
make sure it's of the right species
uh before i forward it to zach um
does that look right to you
yeah well no not all of those are
familiar so some of those are familiar
but not all of them
so um so
kyle who has done a lot of work on kyle
summers made choice
in these frogs has found a positive
assorted of mating
yes i should i have not gone back and
looked at his papers but that's what i
remember
yes so let me just say whether that is
positive assertive mating meaning
um what you are like with regard to
whatever character it is that you're
thinking about uh you tend to choose the
same thing negative assertive mating
being
whatever character you're attending to
you tend to choose the opposite thing in
a mate
so yes they i believe that kyle has
found kyle summers has found
positive assertive mating with regard to
color morph in oophagia pamelio
in the bocas del toro archipelago of
panama that was a lot of words that
probably are meaningless to most people
no but um let's just put it to you this
way there are good reasons that this
could happen
for example color morph may be arbitrary
but it can be an indicator of lineage
and there are reasons that creatures
might prefer to mate at some distance
from self but within lineage so
that is an awkward fact but it uh
nonetheless it's not hard to find
logic by which that would evolutionarily
be favored and i would just say i
in my dissertation i deployed an
argument
whereby this might even work in
plants right and the example i used was
hydrangeas
and the thing is hydrangeas their
color the color of the flowers is
dependent
on soil ph
and my argument was that
plants could use the eyes of insects to
choose a mate
and they would do this if you had a
let's say blue
morph of hydrangea blue morph indicates
what soil type it is growing in so a
plant that has successfully grown in
let's say acidic soils
has gotten to the point of flowering and
is looking for a mate
well its seeds are very likely to end up
in acidic soils because if you had to
guess what soil type the seeds would
land in from an adult if the adult is in
acidic soils
the offspring are liable to end up there
so it wouldn't want a hydrangea that was
well adapted to basic soils
and so how do you figure this out if you
don't have eyes and you can't see your
mate because it's a pollen grain you're
looking for
well you might put up a blue flower to
whatever extent there's a bias in
insects towards blue
or a particular insect toward blue that
insect would tend to go
from a blue hydrangea to a blue
hydrangea rather than from a red
hydrangea to a blue hydrangea
and this could provide some bias whereby
a plant with no eyes could see
a potential mate and choose one over
another flowers
pollinators doing the flowers bidding as
they do in many regards but specifically
having their eyes borrowed yes very good
plants borrowing the eyes of insects
very nice
[Music]
you